une convention admise par tous s'il
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
en france 561 nouveaux décès ces
dernières 24 heures et une très légère
baisse du nombre de patients en
réanimation pour le quatrième jour
consécutif mais le directeur général de
la santé le répète
l'heure n'est pas aux dés confinement
les hôpitaux sont toujours sous pression
dans ce contexte emmanuel macron doit
annoncer de nouvelle mesure demain soir
dont la prolongation du confinement
des centaines de millions de fidèles à
travers le monde célèbrent pâques dans
des conditions inédites ce matin à
l'issue de la messe célébrée cents
fidèles dans la basilique saint-pierre
pour cause de confinement le pape a
donné sa bénédiction urbi et orbi à la
ville et au monde
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale il a notamment proposé la levée
des sanctions
l'annulation des dettes des pays pauvres
et un cessez le feu mondiale
elle les états unis deviennent le pays
le plus touché au monde par la pandémie
avec plus de 20000 morts et le plus
grand nombre de contaminations
alors pour tenter d'endiguer la
propagation les géants du web
s'associent google et apple propose un
outil commun à disposition des
gouvernements pour tracer les malades
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france et on
débute avec le dernier bilan du
ministère de la santé français
concernant le dernier bilan liés aux
coronavirus pour la quatrième journée
consécutive le nombre de patients en
réanimation est en très légère baisse
dans le pays le kobe de 19 a causé la
mort de 14 mille 393 personnes mais les
malades continuent d'affluer dans les
hôpitaux
un dimanche de pâques toujours sous
pression donc le directeur de la santé
jérôme salomon le martèle l'heure n'est
pas aux dés confinement les français
doivent rester chez eux
dans ce contexte emmanuel macron
s'exprimera officiellement demain soir
pour la quatrième fois depuis le début
de la pandémie
le chef de l'état devrait annoncer la
prolongation du confinement probablement
au delà du 10 mai en attendant la
gestion de la crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement est pointé du doigt
seuls 38 % des françaises interrogées
disent lui faire confiance selon un
sondage ifop pour le jdd c'est une chute
de 9 points par rapport à la semaine
dernière concernant l'aide apportée aux
entreprises 45% des sondés soutiennent
l'action de l'exécutif des chiffres là
aussi en baisse est en pleine crise la
praye coronavirus suscite déjà des
remous plusieurs responsables
économiques incite les français à mettre
les bouchées doubles pour permettre un
sursaut économique
hier la secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie a déclaré je cite
il faudra pour bras probablement
travailler plus que nous ne l'avons fait
avant elle réagissait aux propos tenus
par le patron du medef geoffroy roux de
bézieux a remis en question certains
acquis sociaux
l'important c'est de remettre la machine
économique en marche et de reproduire de
la richesse en masse pour tenter
d'effacer dès 2021
les pertes de la croissance de 2020
ensuite il faudra bien se poser la
question tôt ou tard du temps de travail
des jours fériés et des congés payés
pour accompagner la reprise est
facilitée en travaillant un peu plus la
création de croissance supplémentaire
des propos qui ont évidemment fait
réagit
écoutez augmentation du temps de travail
diminution des jours fériés baisse des
cotisations et des impôts de société le
medef a son idée du jour d'après revenir
sur tous les acquis des jours d'avant le
qu'ovide 19 comme cheval de troie
honteux bah voyons
pour le medef et les grands patrons
l'état d'urgence sanitaire c'est
carrément la fête du slip
après tout pourquoi gênés 1 seco vide
c'est cadeau merci macron et pénicaud la
pres a bien commencé
le medef pourrait proposer une taxe sur
les dividendes des actionnaires et la
création d'un grand impôt sur les riches
s il préfère se concentrer pour prendre
le seul bien de ceux qui n'ont pas de
capital le temps alors que le medef
plaide pour augmenter le temps de
travail et diminuer les jours fériés et
les congés payés
interview de geoffroy roux de bézieux ce
samedi il faut au contraire répondre à
la crise du coc vite 19 par la justice
fiscale que chacun paie sa juste part
d'impôts et s'il est possible que le
gouvernement modifie la durée
hebdomadaire de travail il pourrait être
également revenir sur la réforme des
retraites c'est en tout cas ce qu'a
laissé entendre gilles legendre le
président du groupe
lrm à l'assemblée nationale il
s'exprimait dans une interview au jdd la
réforme des retraites a montré à quel
point notre démocratie sociale est
épuisé entre deux réformes utiles il
faudra toujours choisir celle qui
rassemble les français
si elle empêche le pacte républicain de
se conclure la réforme des retraites
devra être mise de côté
et puis le charles de gaulle est de
retour à toulon 50 marins du
porte-avions ont été testés positifs au
co vite 19
ils vont être placés à l'isolément tout
comme les 1900 membres de l'équipage
trois marins ont déjà été évacuées à
titre préventif par avion et transféré
dans un hôpital militaire et l'origine
de la contamination reste toujours un
mystère le bâtiment n'étaient plus en
contact avec l'extérieur depuis le 15
mars à la priorité à présent procéder à
des tests de dépistage de grande ampleur
égouttez le capitaine christine rib en
tout
vous avez sur le porte avions environ
1700 personnes et sur le chevalier paul
environ 200 personnes c'est un petit peu
moins de deux milles marins qui sont mis
en 14ème dans la région sur différentes
emprises militaires
vous imaginez bien que cela nécessite
une manoeuvre une manoeuvre inédite une
manoeuvre concertée aussi puisque tout
cela était partagée avec des autorités
locales sanitaires et politiques pour
permettre un accueil maximale en tout
cas le plus efficace possible et le plus
humain aussi j'insiste de nos mares ce
qui est certain je ne sais pas à quel
moment
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'un
dépistage de l'ensemble des marins est
prévu pendant le confinement notre
objectif c'est vraiment encore une fois
la protection des marins
l'accompagnement des familles la
protection des familles mais aussi la
protection des français donc on veut
faire le maximum pour avoir une
situation la plus créé leur possible
avant de permettre à nos marins de
regagner leurs foyers
donc un dépistage préalable est
nécessaire et en ce dimanche de pâques
direction la réunion où plusieurs
paroisses se mobilisent pour permettre
aux catholiques de pratiquer leur foi
pendant le confinement les réunionnais
ont pu assister à des messes virtuel
comme celles de l'église 2.0 négligent
connecter très présent sur les réseaux
sociaux
un reportage de carole waro et de rania
berrada
[Musique]
souci
ce sont des fêtes de pâques particulière
que célèbrent cette année nathanaël
sandra et leurs enfants à cause des
mesures de confinement ils doivent
suivre la messe depuis chez eux à
sainte-marie au nord de la réunion une
messe virtuels qui ne permet pas de
communes et regrette matanaise c'est bon
qu'il est par ici parce que c'est
vraiment bon jésus ressuscité mayrand
nous c'est vrai que c'est en fait qu'un
avec lui quand on prend car ici on parle
aussi on n'a pas le choix c'est les
conditions et circonstances qui font que
rester confiné donc c'est un mode
dégradé canadien est bien là encore on a
la chance de suivre la messe par les
travers des médias donc c'est bien
sombre est connecté à 2.0 2.0 pour la
messe dominicale et puis parra c'est
celle de simplement
et on va tant l'entente sur les sites
sur capitaux
et puis voilà l'église de zéro une
église créé il ya plus de deux ans avec
pour objectif de reconquérir les jeunes
son point fort sa forte présence sur les
réseaux sociaux qui lui vaut d'être
suivi par beaucoup de fidèles pendant le
confinement
cent mille personnes ont par exemple
regarder en direct la messe du vendredi
saint parmi eux amandine 18 ans la fille
du couple est une fidèle de l'église de
0,1 me suis connecté à leurs pages
instagram facebook et
youtube a été requise
la chaîne qu on a regardé les laisse
tous les dimanches
comme ce matin et que approprié le matin
et le soir et puis
chacun de notre compétence filière
car basée à l'église notre dame de la
salette longtemps laissé à l'abandon
l'église de zéro et perchée sur une
butte avec vue sur la mer et les
cocotiers à l'intérieur aucun banc des
fidèles de 16 à 30 ans reste debout ou
ça soit à même le sol une grande croix
en plexiglas lumineuse change de couleur
selon les temps liturgiques de l'année
et de grands écrans ornent les lieux une
église connectés dont qui se veut proche
de ces jeunes fidèles 2.0 ça fait appel
à l'innovation à la modernité à la mise
à jour des connaissances des vous
utilisez votre téléphone portable vous
êtes en fait 2.0 sans même le savoir et
les jeunes aujourd'hui sont tous 2.0 ça
veut dire qu'ils sont connectés ils sont
sur les réseaux sociaux
ils sont sur facebook snapshot internet
etc et il faut les rejoindre
là où ils sont alors nous avons voulu
faire une église proche
une église qui évangélise les jeunes en
utilisant leurs moyens modernes pour
pouvoir les ramener à la beauté du
message de l'évangile et à faire
connaître jésus christ
cette année pour la messe de pâques
c'est monseigneur gilbert aubry premier
évêque réunionnais qui officie et malgré
ces circonstances particulières il
espère que de nouveaux fidèles
rejoindront l'église après le
confinement
effectivement il ya un manque liturgique
là depuis le
le confinement nullement que creuse
aussi la soif l'intérieur et quand on a
soif alors on envie de boire et ça crée
une soif de l'eucharistie
je pense que il ya une attention plus
grands moulins tente plus grands qui
fait qu'après le confinement
il y aura davantage de pratique car ici
sur l'île de la réunion on compte près
de soixante dix églises et 75 % de la
population est catholique ce qui
représente près de 630 mille fidèles qui
doivent se contenter de metz virtuel
pour le moment quand on regarde le voir
dans le cas dimanche pascal inédit ge
pour plus de deux milliards de chrétiens
dans le manque de mots dans le monde pas
que la fête la plus importante de la
tradition chrétienne commémore la
résurrection du christ et pour la
première fois de son histoire
l église a célébré la messe de pâques
sans fidel c'est donc devant des écrans
on vient de voir à distance que ces
derniers ont suivi ce matin le message
du pape françois après avoir célébré la
messe dans une basilique saint-pierre
vide pour cause de pandémie
le souverain pontife a donné sa
traditionnelle bénédiction urbi et orbi
à la ville et au monde et en cette
période de pandémie
il a notamment proposé d'annuler la
dette des pays les plus pauvres françois
aussi lancé un appel à un allègement des
sanctions internationales et à la
solidarité de l'europe l'europe ou le
nouveau coronavirus a fait plus de
soixante quinze mille morts en italie on
dénombre ce soir 431 décès c'est le
bilan le plus bas de ces trois dernières
semaines rome a décidé d'étendre les
mesures de confinement jusqu'au 3 mai le
pays qui approche les 20 mille morts
malgré un confinement strict lancé le 10
mars dernier le 10 mi-temps très
sévèrement les déplacements et les
rassemblements de l'ensemble des 60
millions d'italiens les derniers
chiffres donnent des signes de
ralentissement dans le pays depuis un
mois
et puis en espagne après trois jours
consécutifs de baisse le nombre de morts
chaque jour repart à la hausse
6 119 décès en 24 heures ce qui porte le
bilan total à près de 17000 le nombre de
nouveaux cas confirmés a en revanche lui
reculé par rapport à hier une espagne
troisième pays le plus endeuillé du
monde derrière les états unis et
l'italie
aujourd'hui le total cumulé des cas avec
la clôture des chiffres d'hier et de
166,19 ce qui représente 67 nouveaux cas
des dernières 24 heures du mans est allé
voir comme ces derniers jours nous
continuons d'enregistrer une
augmentation de 3% du nombre de cas est
une tendance à la baisse ces dernières
semaines en fait cette tendance à la
baisse du nombre total de cas se
maintient depuis le 25 mars et est
encore plus prononcé depuis le 1er avril
réaction également d'ursula von der
weyden la présidente de la commission
européenne préconise un bep confinement
tardif pour les seniors sans vaccin il
faut limiter autant que possible les
contacts des seniors je sais que c'est
difficile et que l' isolement pèse mais
c'est une question de vie ou de mort
nous devons rester discipliné et
patients les enfants et les jeunes
jouiront plutôt de davantage de liberté
de mouvement que les personnes âgées et
celles avec des antécédents médicaux
au royaume uni le nombre de décès
franchi lui le cap des dix mille et
boris johnson est sorti de l'hôpital
londonien il y était traité depuis une
semaine après avoir été contaminés par
le coït 19
il a déclaré je cite que tout aurait pu
basculer pour lui à l'hôpital
écoutez si maintenant le premier
ministre britannique remercier le
royaume uni tout entier ait eu des
élèves transmis entre j'ai quitté
l'hôpital aujourd'hui après une semaine
au cours de laquelle le personnel
médical m'a sauvé la vie sans aucun
doute world speaks presse mais il est
difficile de trouver les mots pour
exprimer ma gratitude et plus loin mais
avant d'en arriver là
je tiens à remercier tout le monde au
royaume uni pour les efforts et les
sacrifices que vous avez fait
et que vous faites encore d'un mec elle
les etats-unis sont depuis hier le pays
le plus touché par le coronavirus le
bilan depuis le début de la pandémie à 2
530 mille personnes contaminées et de
vingt mille décès plus de 2000 personnes
ont succombé à la maladie au cours des
seules dernières 24 heures la ville de
new york est particulièrement touchée à
pour lutter contre la propagation
d'épidémies les deux géants apple et
google ont annoncé travailler à un outil
de traçage social pour permettre de
lutter contre la maladie
alors en quoi est-ce que cela consiste
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
l'amérique du sud est également touché
par le virus en argentine ce sont plus
de 2000 cas officiel pour 90 morts le
gouvernement a prolongé jusqu'au 26
avril
le confinement obligatoire dans les
grandes villes pour tenter de contenir
la pandémie avec un taux de pauvreté de
plus de 35% une situation économique à
l'agonie à la vie est de plus en plus
difficile pour de nombreux argentins
france pâtissier mitch la file d'attenté
plus longs que d'habitude devant
l'église de san cayetano petite ville de
la province de buenos aires est ce ici
chaque jour des bénévoles distribuent
des repas pour les plus démunis et avec
la pandémie
la situation s'est dégradée pour de
nombreux argentins
oui pire parce que je travaille au noir
et depuis la pandémie je ne reçoit pas
d'argent au total ce sont plus de 3
millions de personnes supplémentaires
qui ont besoin de l'aide alimentaire du
gouvernement les personnes qui faisait
partie du programme d' aide alimentaire
mais qu'ils avaient des petits emplois
de temps en temps entre ait quitté le
programme est bien ces gens là ont
aujourd'hui besoin de plus d aides la
demande l'aide alimentaire est passé de
8 millions à 11 millions de personnes le
5 avril dernier
des queues interminables se sont formées
devant les banques fermé depuis 15 jours
en raison du confinement de nombreux
argentins sans compte bancaire sont
venus retirer au guichet les aide
exceptionnelle allouée par le
gouvernement aux familles pauvres mais
aussi les retraités pour leur pension
mensuelle
je ne peux pas attendre je veux être
payés parce que je dois nourrir mes
enfants je viens ici parce que je n'ai
rien d'autre
la seule chose que j'ai l'intention j'ai
passé toute la nuit ici parce que j'en
ai besoin
j'ai subi deux traumatismes crâniens et
j'ai besoin d'argent pas pour manger
parce que je survis avec du thé et du
pain et je ne peux pas survivre sans le
manque de médicaments
plongée dans la récession depuis bientôt
deux ans les
conomie argentine est fortement affectée
par la crise liée aux coronavirus pour y
faire face le gouvernement du président
alberto fernandez a repoussé à 2021 le
paiement de neuf milliards 800 millions
de dollars de dette publique
une astuce qui devrait donner un peu
d'air au pays mais pas pour très
longtemps
d'ici la fin de l'année les autorités
devront verser quelques 3 milliards 500
millions de dollars à leurs créanciers
internationaux
sans cette fois la possibilité de
pouvoir repousser l'échéance direction
la turquie endeuillée avec plus de 1100
morts les hôpitaux s'arment de patience
et tentent de contenir comme ils peuvent
l'afflux de patients atteints du coït 19
david khalfa alliés gone 12 93 ans
sortis guéris d'un hôpital d'istanbul
après 10 jours de traitement contre le
coc u19 une petite victoire pour les
médecins et infirmières qui ont laissé
éclater leur joie dans un tonnerre
d'applaudissements avec plus de 47000
qu'à la turquie est l'un des dix pays
les plus touchés par la pandémie
la progression il est l'une des plus
rapides au monde
en première ligne face à un ennemi
invisible
les soignants turc luttent jour et nuit
essuyant eux aussi des pertes
un médecin et morts et plus de 600 ont
été contaminées le personnel de
l'hôpital où les équipes
tous travaillent ardemment comme s'ils
étaient en guerre l'ambiance ici ne
ressemble pas un lieu de travail mais
plutôt à un champ de bataille
environ 60% des cas de couronnes à virus
en turquie ont été recensés à istanbul
ville tentaculaire de plus de 15
millions d'habitants et capitale
économique du pays
dès l'apparition des premiers cas en
turquie mi mars
l'hôpital sera pas agrandi l'unité des
soins intensifs et séparer la section
dédiée aux nouveaux coronavirus dont les
entrées sont strictement contrôlés de
peur de contaminer leurs proches
certains membres du personnel soignant
dorment à l'hôtel ou dans des résidences
étudiantes reconverti en centre
d'hébergement
afin de ne pas infecter ma famille j'ai
déménagé depuis près d'un mois
maintenant je ne suis pas logées à
l'hôtel mais je vis à proximité avec un
collègue médecin en isolement
une lutte qui se traduit aussi dans les
rues d'istanbul plongé dans un silence
inédit
les habitants des 30 plus grandes villes
de turquie n'ont plus le droit de sortir
de chez eux jusqu'à dimanche soir un
couvre feu de 48 heures prévue au
dernier moment et qui a créé un vent de
panique à travers tout le pays
en tunisie la jeunesse est sur tous les
fronts pour lutter contre la propagation
du coronavirus confection de masques
sensibilisation des populations
opérations de décontamination
les initiatives se multiplient dans le
pays à un reportage réalisé par ben
hassen chébili et eser nasri à tunis
c'est une journée comme toutes les
autres depuis le début du confinement
pour des cra cette jeune styliste de la
banlieue nord de tunis
comme de nombreux tunisiens et face à la
suspension de son activité
elle a décidé de mettre son savoir faire
au profit de la communauté celle qui
tous les jours doit faire face
coronavirus il est même geste qu'elle
réalise un rassemblement pour
confectionner ces masques et les
distribuer gratuitement
je vois beaucoup de personnes dehors
sans masque que je vois surtout les
employés municipaux sans masque il ya
même des personnes qui n'ont pas les
moyens de s'en acheter
j'ai donc décidé de confectionner des
masques et de les distribuer dans un
premier temps aux employés municipaux
qui sont en première ligne notamment
avec le ramassage des ordures et c'est
après que j'ai eu l'idée d'élargir cette
distribution personnes les plus
nécessiteuses et aux bénévoles dans la
mesure où j'ai dû fermer mon atelier et
j'ai décidé de déménager mon matériel
chez moi pour éviter tout contact et me
concentrer sur la réalisation de ses
basques
aujourd'hui je dois en finir une
cinquantaine que je vais aller livrer au
croissant rouge
mon champ de pétrole de demain comme
l'or
employée de mairie le scout ou encore
croissant rouge
la livre ses créations quotidiennement
et directement
l'occasion pour elle d' échanger avec
ses héros du quotidien et de puiser
l'énergie nécessaire pour continuer sa
mission
une initiative très appréciée pour ses
bénévoles du croissant rouge
en pleine crise du court on a un virus
on a besoin de tous les efforts de la
société civile de leur aide et quart à
nous seuls on ne peut pas gérer toute
cette situation
on remercie toutes les personnes qui
contribuent à notre protection surtout
que nous travaillons dans un espace clos
depuis le début de la pandémie les
initiatives citoyennes se multiplient à
travers tout le pays face aux actions du
gouvernement jugée insuffisante
ils sont nombreux ces jeunes a contribué
à cette lutte contre le virus qui a
fragilisé tout un pays déjà frappé par
une crise sociale et économique où les
jeunes sont en première ligne chez les
scouts de sidi daoud dans la banlieue
nord de tunis venir en aide à la
population est un devoir inscrire dans
leurs valeurs chaque jour ils se
réunissent pour faire un point avant
leur mission de décontamination de leur
quartier en matant venait de finir votre
débriefing ici chez les scouts de tunis
c'est le début d'opérations du coup
sa mission c'est comment on va bouger
que c'est qu'est ce qu'il va faire
qu'est ce qu'il a à faire
comment protéger lui ses camarades aussi
lors de cette opération
ici tous les ventes volontaires ont une
idée sur le coronavirus comment protéger
comment se protéger en vis-à-vis ce
virus et comment protéger leurs familles
le reste du citoyen de sidi des masques
blues ou encore désinfectant ils sont
parés à s'attaquer à une nouvelle
parcelle de leur commune un devoir
citoyen que beaucoup d'entre eux
prennent thacker vous nous expliquer un
peu ce que vous faites la roma n'a
jamais nous sommes en train de déserter
ce quartier après avoir lu monarchie un
loup très important où se rassemblent
beaucoup au monde avec c'était notre
priorité aujourd'hui on s'attaque donc à
cette rue là c'est une mission très
importante pour moi et je m'en
souviendrai toujours le jour où je me
suis protégé et que j'ai protégé les
autres voilà pourquoi je suis là
aujourd'hui en tunisie les 15-29 ans
représentent 24 5% de la population
une tranche d'âge de plus en plus
mobilisés dans la société civile est
bien décidé à participer à cette lutte
collective contre le corps d'un virus et
avant de se quitter cet incident au
congo brazzaville un airbus 330 d'air
france a été endommagé par des balles
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de pointe
noire selon la direction de l'aviation
civile cité par nos confrères de rfi est
ce là cela ferait suite à une
altercation entre des éléments de la
gendarmerie les frontières l'appareil
devait décoller aujourd'hui avec 110
passagers à bord des ressortissants
français
air france assure être sur le point
d'achever mines et un avion de rechange
en attendant lé passager sont prises en
charge
le vol prévu à 10 heures a été reporté
de 24 heures afin de permettre
d'acheminer un appareil de remplacement
et un équipage depuis paris charles de
gaulle
les clients étaient avertis et pris en
charge par nos équipes locales
la sécurité de nos clients et de nos
équipages et notre priorité absolue et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus de
trente minutes restez avec nous sur rt
france à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
e
nous allons évoquer ici les sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants dieu
la première erreur de notes
administration a été de croire que les
terroristes étaient des loups solitaires
alors qu'ils étaient la résultante de 15
ans de travail de fond fait par les
analystes soyons clairs ils ont prêché
la guerre sainte